the six and eight vertex models and
Counting prophet mentioned will be
presented by pinion yeah thank you so
much for this opportunity to talk about
my work I'm a fifth-year PhD at the
University of Wisconsin / professor
genes I was sitting here so in this talk
I will briefly talk about our work on
the six and eight vertex models and
Counting perfect matchings this is a
joint work with my divisor and pn loop
we software sitting here and dingy so
before I start I want to mention that
the main technique we use here is to
give the first approximation scheme is
to my MC MC which is mentioning in by
the last talk by pew as far as I know
there is no result on the zeros of the
polynomial partition function so far but
this is a problem that some of you have
looked at ads like what years ago it at
least afford the unweighted case so it
might be still interesting for you to
look at this model with me
so let's get started so first about the
six or tax model this model was
introduced by Linus Pauling in 1935 to
describe the property of water ice in
water ice each oxygen has four nearest
neighbors with oho bounce and each
hydrogen is in two possible positions
it's either closer to one oxygen or
another and each oxygen must be
surrounded by two hydrogen's near to it
and two on the far side this is called
the ice condition and professor LED
visiting here Thank You professor Dilip
can see the square ice which is a
two-dimensional version of realize and
it's defined by the same ice condition
but applied to the square lattice so
here is a state's valid state in the six
or tax model and you can see that for
each vertex
vertex as a oxygen here there are two
hydrogen near to it and two on the far
side and one very important discovery in
statistical mechanics is the following
if we denote the number of oxygens by N
and the Z to be the partition function
which is also the number of valid
configuration in this model then this
exact solution which is defined to be
the partition function per vertex as the
number of oxygens goes to infinity is
equal to 4 over 3 to the 3 over 2 this
is called the leap square ice constant
so some of you may have noticed that if
we model these oxygens as a vertex and
this hydrogen's as arrows if it's close
to one oxygen and we model it as an
arrow going in if we is far from one
vertex here we mother as an arrow going
out then the states are just or layering
orientations on for regular graphs so
there are six permitted type of local
configuration around the vertex because
of four choose two of edges are going in
so there are six possible weights W 1 2
w 6 and it's the odd it is often assumed
in physics that if we reverse every
arrow around the vertex and get another
configuration these configurations
should have the same way this called
arrow reversal symmetry so in this case
we study this model when W 1 could the W
2 equal to a and these two states have
weight B and these two states have with
C so the partition function is defined
to be the weighted sum of all valid or
levering orientations for each or
levering orientation its weight it
defined to be the product on the
vertices so in addition to water ice
with ABC being one one one several other
crystals with hydrogen banks also
specify the model for example the KDP
model where a Z could be a larger than C
or the resep model where a is equal to B
less than C the exact solutions for
these models and some other generalized
models have been obtained as
well in the sense of thermodynamic limit
in physics so in cabrillo science we
stopped in compare signs we studied the
complexity of computing the partition
function the exact computation of
complexity has been studied a lot for
the unweighted version where we compute
the number of oil area orientations it
is sharp P complete even our planner for
regular graphs and recently there are
some work on the sixth or Tex model
partition function under complex ways
the first is by its - chef who proved a
complexity dichotomy for general for
regular graphs and another work is by
its - a shell who proved the complexity
trichotomy for the planar for regular
graphs in both - works cancellation
plays an important role for polynomial
time computable cases I will talk in a
in a second so under our study with
error reversal symmetry and ABC being
non-negative the the the criteria is
explicit as follows only on these two
cases the problem is tractable for
planner and non planar graphs on these
two cases the problem is tractable only
on planar graphs but not on general
graphs and for all other parameter
settings the problem is sharpy hard so
this is called the trichotomy but
without this planner tractability a
discarded I called me for general graphs
so as you can see except for very
limited cases the problem are Sharpie
hard everywhere so that's why we want to
study the approximate computational
complexity for computer partition
function we studied many for a general
for regular graphs
just to understand determine and always
equals exact so we deny McLean
intractable tribulation of partition
function for finding God right yeah
so here are some of the previous results
on approximate counting and simply so
Mahalo Winkler in 1992 gave an FPS for a
number of other orientations on general
or al-arian graphs
Looby Randall and Sinclair proved rapid
mixing of a Markov chain that leads to a
faster sampling scheme for whatever
orientations and rectangular regions of
the square lattice with fixed boundaries
rendered totally improve the results of
rapid mixing of the single site global
dynamics still with fixed boundaries and
Gober Martine Patterson improved the
previous or previous results to the
rapid mixing on three boundary
conditions but you know that all these
result previous results are on the
points ABC being one one one in the
parameter space and we give the result
that first time go beyond on way to the
case and our result interesting or
interesting confirm to the phase
transition phenomenon in physics so let
me briefly introduce the phenomenon of
phase transition for the six vertex
model before I go to describe our result
the transition phase transition was
described by Ronnie Buxton in his famous
book on the square lattice the weight
APC determine the relative probabilities
of states and thus can influence the
macroscopic behavior of the system so I
won't I will only give a brief
introduction for those who are
interested please check this book so the
phase transition is saying when on the
square lattice region with its silence
approaching infinity this call in the
thermodynamic limit in statistical
physics when a is larger than B plus C
the whole system tends to be frozen in
one of the two states where in this
state every vertex it look like
looks like configuration one in another
states every vertex look like
configuration two and these are the two
states that has the height the possible
weights
and we say it's in the ferroelectric
phase because everything look the same
and in short we write F E and when P is
larger than a plus C we say it's also in
the ferroelectric phase and a symmetric
symmetric to the above case where it
tends to be frozen into two states where
everybody looks like this or everyone
looks like this and when C is larger
than a plus B we call these two type
states saddle configurations with
computer in five and configuration six
the system tends to be frozen into two
states where settle configurations
alternate and in this case we call it in
the anti ferroelectric phase because
everything alternates and when no one is
dominating another tool in ABC we say
the system is in a disordered phase
because no one single state dominates
okay so the this is the phase transition
diagram plotted here where we make C
normalized to 1 and when C is equal to 0
is at the infinite far away which we
didn't plot in this diagram and our
result says there is an FPS fast
approximation scheme for the partition
function if we're in the blue region
where a square is less than equal to B
square plus C square P Square is less
than or equal to a square plus C square
and C square is less than or equal to a
squared plus B squared this is inside
the disorder the face for the whites
region it is still open and there is no
FPS not for parameter settings not in a
disorder the face which in the
ferroelectric phase and anti-fairy
electric phase
this is for general for regular graphs
that's that's for any particular
labeling you can choose the labeling ABC
for the six you can label edge one two
three four in a way that you like lustre
/ - care of officer so this is an
interesting curve this corresponds to C
square equal equal to a a square plus B
Square which is in exactly
communicational exact computational
complexity is tractable by the Fatiha
f kt algorithm
so let me give a proof sketch for the
this can be can be map to perfectly
matching only on planar graphs so it is
sorry it is intractable only on planar
graphs because the FK tip I will only
work for planar graphs so that's move
I've tried to give a proof sketch of the
faster personation algorithm result so
we as I said we use counting wire
sampling the Markov chain Monte Carlo
technique the algorithm specific
algorithm we use that is called the
directed loop algorithm where the state
space are allowing orientations and year
or Alerian orientations an orientation
on the edges we call near or lair or
Alerian if still every vertex satisfy
the two in to out ice condition but
there are exactly two edges if we if we
view a single edge as two half edges
these two half edges disagree so we
allow near allowing orientations like
this and the transition of this Markov
chains metropolis moves between
neighboring states once data is neighbor
to another state if it's creating
shifting or merging of two defects on
the edges for example from the states
want to state the two it creates two
defects around this vertex from the
second state to the third state it
shifted relative effect from this edge
to another edge incident to the same
vertex and from this state to this state
it merges this two defects
so this Markov chain will actually used
a lot in the fifth in the literature
especially by statistical mechanics
mainly for studying the numerical
properties of the sick vertex model and
one interesting fact about this Markov
chain is that it depicts the like
natural defects happening in the real
wise
so here comes with technical lemma so in
order to prove an FPS we have to prove
the rapid mixing of a Markov chain so
let me use this Z sub 0 to denote the
total weight of oil our orientation
which is also the partition function
we're interested in compute and Z sub 2
to be the total weight of near well
every orientation then the technical
lemma says if Z 2 over Z 0 is
polynomially upper bounded then the
Markov chain is rapid mixing in the blue
region so this doesn't give the rapid
mixing but gives a condition when if we
can prove this Z 2 over 0 Z 0 is bounded
we have the rapid mixing this lemma was
proved by a canonical path argument in
our paper it can also be derived by
techniques of Mac : in the framework of
wine nobility and we show that Z Z Z 2
over Z 0 is indeed polynomial upper
bounded in the whole disordered phase
not just the blue region so this will
give you a F PS for the blue region but
we proved something more here and the
following structure lemma plays a
crucial role before stating the lemma
let me introduce the notion of a for
reconstruction it is a for regular graph
having four external edges so inside
there vertices edges we're where I
didn't draw them and this for
reconstruction defines the constraint
function the value the value of on the
inputs on the four external edges is the
weighted sum of that all valid internal
configurations consistent with the input
so this is a gadget that defines it
turns out that the constraint function
of this for reconstruction also satisfy
the ice rule and the arrow reversal
symmetry if everything inside is
satisfied so this gadget can be viewed
as a virtue over
in the six for tax model for some a
prime B prime C part that we don't know
if unless we compute them and our
structural lemma says the set of 4 e
constraint functions lying in the
disordered face is close to under 4
reconstructions it means that if you
start with vertices in the disordered
phase which you get as a constraint
function of the four reconstruction is
still in the disordered phase this lemma
is important not only for its crucial
role in giving FPS but also reveals the
structural difference between the two
sides of the phase transition threshold
so let's see how can we prove the
structural lemma we use the idea of
decomposition of oil erroring
orientations for each or levering
orientation we decompose the orientation
at each vertex in the phone wave with
hair incoming edge edges two outgoing
edges in two possible ways and this will
give us for each alluring orientation
can give us two to the number of
vertices many circuit partitions so I
exhibition position here so this is the
indicator if it's 1 it means there is a
decomposition into this parry for this
configuration and you can check this is
indeed correct
so the idea of decomposition also works
for for ik constructions for if you look
at this gadget suppose we have an
orientation for this gadget where it
goes in from e1 and E 4 and goes out at
e2 and e3 if we decompose every vertex
inside it's possible that we get a
circuit and trail decomposition where
finally one goes to e 2 and e 4 goes to
e 3 it's also possible that II 1 goes to
e 3 E 4 goes to e 2 it depends on the
internal structure it depends on the way
you decompose so in if it's like this we
say you want need to are globally paired
together for this for reconstruction and
we can put weights on the local parents
at vertices and define the weight of a
circuit and Composition to be the
product on weights on vertices and we
can define the induced weight capital W
of global pairings for the for
reconstruction at the virtual vertex for
example we can define the capital W of
this kind of parry to be the weight to
the sum of all circuit decompositions
where e1 and e2 a paired up III and E fo
are paired up so if we make the previous
idea of decomposition into a weighted
one and solve this linear equation set
of equations then we get a following the
constraint function ABC is in the
disordered phase at every vertex if and
only if the weights of pairings are all
non-negative at every vertex locally and
this indicates the weight of circuit
partition of the for reconstruction are
non-negative because the weight of the
product are I an issue vertex so the
induced the weight function kept the W
for the global parents of the for
reconstruction or are also non-negative
and this is if and only if construct
functions of the for reconstruction a
prime B prime C prime is in the
disordered phase so this proved the
closure property as
the structural Emma so I will skip the
proof sketch for the harness part but I
want to mention that we use an
approximation a prism reduction yes
previously
[Music]
yeah so it has to be combined with the
technical lemma here so our technical
says if it's polynomial bounded then
it's rapid mixing and this does not give
F P us we need to do more but it's the
key point here
so for the hardness parts I won't give
the proof but we use an approximation
preserving reduction from the maximum
independent set on three regular grams
so let's move on to the the eight vertex
model this time we have two more local
configurations which are the sinks and
sources so we still insist the error
reversal symmetry and given the same
weight D and the six vertex model is
just a special case when D is equal to
zero in the States this time are not
allowing orientation anymore they are
even orientations for each even
orientation eat every vertex should be
in one of the eight states local
configuration here and we can we can
similarly define the partition function
so we still have the phase transition
phenomenon from physics we have one more
anti ferroelectric phase when D is
larger than a plus B plus C the system
tends to be frozen into exactly one of
two states where the sinks and sources
alternate and for the disorder phase we
have one more inequalities here so let
me plot our result in this kind of
diagram we because we're in a four
dimensional space this time so it's very
hard to plug exactly where they are so I
use this line diagram diagram first
result is we still have the NP hardness
of approximation the partition function
in the ferroelectric phase and for anti
ferroelectric phase and this is by an
approximation presuming reduction from
the maximum cut on three regular graphs
and I will keep on filling in details in
the disordered phase so please allow me
to use the square sum to denote the
region where among the four squares one
square is less than or equal to the
other three and we mark here this
regions a sub region of the disordered
phase and here's a wonderful result we
can still show that a variation of the
direct loop algorithm for the six vertex
model still have the rapid mixing a
property if Z 2 over Z 0 is polynomially
upper bounded this is using a similar
connect canonical path argument which
allow me to use this Tisa to denote this
region where a plus D is less than or
equal to B plus C B plus D less than or
equal to a plus C C plus D less than or
equal to a plus B this is again another
region that's inside the disordered
phase and we show that in the D some
region we can indeed polynomial bound
the
the Z 2 over Z 0 so in the intersection
we have an FPS at this time in order to
prove this property for this region we
have to we use the decomposition of even
orientation but the orient decomposition
is different from the one we use for the
second vertex model this time we
decompose for an even orientation we
decompose each the edges around each
vertex in all three possible ways
because we have a sink or source at
locally at the vertex so it's not
possible to always pair incoming edges
with outgoing edges but when we do this
pairing we give them a sign so if we are
pairing incoming edges with incoming
edges for example in this pairing for
this configuration we give them a minus
sign to indicate that you have
conflicting orientation to you so we do
not only have three kind of pairings for
each vertex we have actually six
it's either each one of them with either
a plus sign or a minus sign so we have
six possible ways of decompose and you
can see that for sink and sinks and
sources every possible decomposition
pairs incoming edges with incoming edges
outgoing edges with outgoing edges so
they always have minus signs here in
order to convince you I will give you an
example of a decomposition of a two
vertex four edges graph if is of this
even orientation then because at each
vertex there are three ways to decompose
it so in total there are nine ways to
decompose this this single even
orientation notice that for for example
notice this specific decomposition where
this has a plus sign this also has a
pastime it also appears in the
decomposition of another even
orientation which also has nine possible
ways to decompose but they share
only this decomposition because of the
rules we specify here
so first closure property for the eight
vertex model the set of fully constrain
functions excuse me
lying in the disorder phase is close to
under for reconstruction this again
reveals a structure difference a
structural difference between the two
sides of the phase transition threshold
the proof idea is the following under
the weighted version of the
decomposition we solve this set of
equations and get a following if ABCD is
in the disordered phase it is if only
and if and only if there exists a non
negative weight function on the pairings
and this indicates that induce the
weight function
kept the W of pairings for the for
reconstruction as a virtual vertex are
also non-negative and so the constraint
function for the for reconstruction is
also lying in the disorder phase so this
is kind of similar to the procedure for
the six vertex mode in the disordered
phase another lemma says the set of four
constraint functions line the D sub
region is closed on the four
reconstructions and this closure
property directly indicates that Z 2
over Z 0 is polynomially upper bounded
and the Profi the phone still under the
same way to decomposition here ABCD is
the decent region if and only if for
each type of pairing with outside the
weights of this parent with a plus sign
is no less than the weight of the same
parent with a minus sign this is by
directly solve this and in this decent
region and we managed to prove this
non-trivial statement that the induced
the weight function capital W also for
the global pairing also has this
property so the construction function
for the for reconstruction is also in a
d sub region
so yeah now we really have an FPS in the
intersection of the two regions shown
here we still want to understand what
are the computational complexity for
approximating partition functions for
the parts that we don't have algorithm
we didn't prove hardness yet and we're
able to link the complexity of
approximating the partition function for
the a to vertex model outside the D some
region to the problem of approximately
counting perfect matchings on general
graphs so we our result is outside the D
some region the problem of computing the
partition function of the a to vertex
model is at least as hard as a problem
approximately computing the perfect
matching under approximation with
preserving reductions again I'm not
going to show the proof here but what
I'm going to show is the following so we
know that outside of this region it is
sharp p.m. hard and we want to ask when
it's sharp en easy and we showed that
inside the square sub region the problem
is indeed sharp PM easy we show this by
giving the approximation presuming
reduction from the problem to
approximate the number of weighted
perfect matching so in order to prove
this theorem we use the notion of for a
match gates it is a graph with K
external edges external edges are
labeled I sub 1/2 I sub K and each non
external edge II has a non negative
weight W sub II this defines a function
constraint function f on the K external
edges where F on a specific input is the
weighted sum over all the perfect
matchings that are consistent with the
external input on the external edges
so in order to show sharp p.m. easiness
we show that every eight vertex
constraint function represented by an
ABCD inside this square some region can
be implemented by a for image match gate
so the four ramesh gates we use is just
a complete six complete graph on six
vertices with four external edges and we
we can put the non-negative weights on
each between the on the edge between
each two vertex IJ a weight W sub IJ and
these are the functions constraint
functions that we can express so for the
eight red hex model these eight values
are exactly corresponds to the weights
on the eight configurations we have to
show that we can set the non negative
value of W sub 1 2 and so on so forth by
setting these non-negative values on the
edges we can get every point in a square
some region and it reduced this to the
following in geometric Clemmie so if we
let u to be a polyhedron given by these
inequalities V to be a bounded face X
plus y plus Z is equal to 1 with X Y Z
being non negative and W be another
polyhedron then the lemma says u the
polyhedron you is the Minkowski sum of V
and W namely u consists of precisely
those points vector u such that vector U
is equal to vector V Plus vector W for
some vector V in capital V and vector W
in capital and the proof we use is also
a geometric one so the red triangle in
this mesh three dimensional space are
the boundaries for this
we the blue race are the intersections
of the facets for the polyhedron W and
the green race together with this red
triangle are the intersections of the
seven facets of the polyhedron u so in
order to show this lemma we have to
prove that by moving by shifting this
blue polyhedron on the surface of this
red triangle we can reach every point
inside this green polyhedron and then
nothing else and we prove this by the
following we first put this vertex of
this blue polyhedron on one vertex of
the red triangle and shift it along the
three edges of this right triangle and
this will cover every point for the
polyhedron you except for the
tetrahedron the the red tetrahedron here
and in order to fill everything in this
tetrahedron we just use a vector that's
perpendicular a a vector in the blue
region that's perpendicular to this red
triangle and swype the face the surface
of this red triangle and this finish the
proof
so combining the sharp p.m. easiness and
harness result we know this region in
the square some region but outside the
decent region the problem is equivalent
to counting perfect matchings in the
approximation of innocence so our result
extra-tight because no ABCD outside the
square some region can be implemented by
a forum educate this is essentially due
to both of Goldberg Jim rich Ben's
evening and in fact we have a theorem of
independent interest it is open for
several years what are the constraint
functions that can be implemented by non
negatively weighted Karim educate for K
larger than three we gave we give the
characterization for four images they
are essentially those satisfying this
kind of condition I'm being a little
vague on describing the constraint
functions but one can check out our
paper for details for the statement of
the theorem so last but not least we
actually also have a result and FPS on
planar graphs that's inside the disorder
face but outside the decent region so on
general graphs is proved we prove it's a
number p.m. hard to approximate this
problem for for general graphs but we
show for planograms
we do have FPS with out and for problems
inside this little square these are the
first problems that we know as far as we
know that has this property
and for open problems the approximation
of the partition function here is an
open problem we show that Z 2 over Z 0
is polynomial bounded but if there an
FPS for this region also the other open
problem is we show for the disorder
phase outside of this box is counting
p.m. heart but as I said it's not
possible to use match gate to show p.m.
equivalence in this region so we would
like to ask if it's p.m. equivalent or
if it's even hotter or if it's in
between yes yes yes so the work I
present here is for general for regular
graphs which is not restricted to square
lattice or it actually square lattice
with different kind of boundary
conditions except for the tourists
except for the tourists there are not
for regular graphs in the graph theory
but we also have some results on the
square lattice but that's another story
yes yes but we ask for a for irregular
graph we ask it has no like external
edges no open boundaries for this our
result of the approximation result the
FPS without the works for the torus of
course because it's for regular graph in
the graph theoretical sense but the
hardness doesn't quite work because in
heart in the proof of the hardness we
use a lot of construct
that's highly non square lattice like I
have some result I can talk to you after
this for the square lattice the boundary
condition that would give you the
maximum number of possibilities is just
found these but it took many years to
prove I didn't know that in fact the
periodic boundary conditions gave me the
same interview yes yes I know that
result yes you know we're talking about
for regular graphs so if it's a three
dimensional it has like more than four
edges yes and we have a discover six or
a tax model right so six is because for
two is six the reset model this has a
very interesting edit feature mainly
advanced phase transitions as you know
is he varying the parameters and what is
remarkable as several remarkable
features but one is that if you go off
the real axis
they like to feel the whatever become
complex then of course you'll end up
with analytic functions for a while and
then there's a boundary
in the case of the easy model the
boundary is when you hit the unit circle
but it almost the president of all cases
this analytic continuation across the
boundary it's an undercover to the
sheets that cross at the bandage so for
the easy model it's the case at least
some of them but in this case you'll end
up with the boundaries for the model
where there's no analytic continuation
anywhere possible it might be different
when there are external fields all right
as a function of these things change
Thanks
[Applause]